voilà une information qui a fait grand
bruit une information selon laquelle de
nombreux soignants positif au qu'ovide
continuerai à travailler dans les
établissements de santé en france pour
faire face à la recrudescence des
hospitalisations l'administration et
leur hiérarchie ont demandé de continuer
à travailler qu'une situation sanitaire
déplorable qui mettrait en danger la
santé des patients et celle de leurs
collègues négatif pourtant si cela peut
paraître fou c'est une pratique
autorisée par le haut conseil de santé
publique je trouve ça grave qu'on met en
danger les usagers et des soignants ou
chu de nantes par exemple les cas de
personnes positives qui travaillent se
multiplient une situation inquiétante
sur laquelle s'est exprimée olivier
therrien le secrétaire général cgt du
chu la sécurité sociale dit aujourd'hui
que si vous êtes contacter si vous êtes
positif
vous devez être isolé nous c'est tout le
contraire avant de mettre en cause le
manque de personnel dans les
établissements de santé
la pierre est vraiment a lancé à
l'administration ciel lancés des
recrutements ça permettrait d'écarter
les professionnels qui sont testés
positifs et de pouvoir les remplacer une
situation que de nombreux hôpitaux
déplorent en france alors soignants
positif est toujours au travail
choquée
j'ai quand même avec cette question donc
est ce que vous êtes choqués je voudrais
vous demande d'applaudir maintenant
notre notre invité aujourd'hui bonsoir
thierry amouroux vous êtes le porte
parole du syndicat national des
professionnels de notre invitation et
d'être avec nous ce soir
c'est vrai que quand on voit ce
reportage c'est assez édifiant on est on
est inquiet nous et on est inquiet
d'abord pour le personnel soignant et
puis pour nous mêmes on se dit mais dans
quelle situation ubuesque sommes-nous
est d'abord est ce que vous confirmez
qu'il y à du personnel soignant qui
était positif et qui malgré tout est
amené à travailler à l'hôpital
tout à fait c'est c'est ce qui est le
plus scandaleux pour nous parce que ça
va à l'encontre d'autres déontologie à
savoir qu' on nous demande de devenir
des agents de contamination auprès de
patients hospitalisés donc fragile donc
que vont développer la forme grave de la
maladie et donc derrière cette décision
de la bureaucratie
il ya des morts il ya des gens qui vont
mourir parce qu'on demande à des
soignants infirmiers médecins de
continuer à travailler alors qu'ils sont
porteurs du virus
ils sont porteurs asymptomatiques un c
sas pour certains c'est à dire qu'il
vienne travailler ils ont malgré tout
quand même j'imagine la protection c'est
à dire le gel et le masque mais en
revanche la distanciation est impossible
quand on en prend tout des soins et donc
vous dites que ils vont ya une
possibilité qu'il contamine un patient
qui lui est sain et qui vient peut-être
pour autre chose
bien sûr bien sûr parce que ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre c'est que vous avez
aussi tous les patients n'ont que vides
qui sont sacrifiés depuis cette crise
c'est à dire que pendant trois mois
tous les patients chroniques non que
vides
ils ont été mis à l'écart pour
concentrer tous les moyens sur les
patients le coc vide alors déjà ça a été
difficile
et cet été on a essayé on a fait
beaucoup d'heures supplémentaires pour
essayer de rattraper un peu du temps non
on n'y est pas on n'y est pas encore
mais derrière tout ça il
il ya des patients chroniques qui
meurent parce qu'ils n'ont pas été pris
dans les temps ce que vous racontez
quand même absolument incroyable sur sa
longue dit beaucoup quand même sur
l'état de la situation de des chu en
france
justement on a vu un infirmier expliquer
pourquoi j'ai décidé de retourner
travailler
malgré avoir été testé positif aux
coronavirus regarde mal à la nuque
fatigue mal de tête les symptômes de
gates ont sont légers malgré tout
étonnamment il a décidé de continuer à
travailler de ne pas se mettre en
quarantaine sans regret plus facile pour
moi de pouvoir la respecter mais d'être
en contact avec différentes directions
infirmières dans les hôpitaux
je sais que il ya pas le choix avec le
personnel soignant est défaillant on
manque de personnel soignant et si on
enlève maintenant entre 20 et 30% du
personnel soignant qui peut être testé
positif
la machine s'effondre la phrase moi qui
me frappe c'est il n'y a pas le choix
cette phrase là elle j'imagine qu'elle
est difficile à accepter aussi pour vous
parce que le personnel soignant a depuis
longtemps alerté sur l'état la précarité
la difficulté et le manque c'est quoi la
solution ce qu'il faut vraiment c'est un
plan marshall pour l'hôpital pour ré
ouvrir des lits d'urgence vous rendez
compte que nous sommes le seul pays du
monde qui continue à fermer des lits en
pleine période d'épidémie
depuis le déconfinement les hôpitaux
sont amenés à fermer des lits pour des
mesures d économies y compris les lits
de réanimation comme les quatorze lits
de réanimation fermé au chu de
strasbourg nous on nous dit que c'est
pas simplement d'ouvrir des lits parce
que d'acheter des lits parce que j'étais
délit s'il n'y a pas de personnel
soignant bas ça servira à rien et vous
êtes d'accord avec ça le fait que de
toute façon il n'y a pas de personnel
soignant quoi donc
on manque pas d'infirmière en france on
en forme 26 mille par an il ya 180 mille
infirmières qui pourraient travailler
qui ont choisi de ne plus travailler
comme comme infirmière parce que on leur
propose des postes dans des cons
situation maltraitance si on vous dit
vous pouvez être que je vous propose un
poste d'infirmier en ehpad pour 80 à 120
résidents ou un poste dans un service
l'hôpital avec 15 patients de métier
donnerait de chirurgie qui ont beaucoup
de soin vous allez être maltraitant
métier mais oui regardez justement
arnaud schiste quelle fondateur du
collectif santé en danger
ils dénoncent le manque d'organisation
il appelle les autorités à prendre des
mesures plus efficaces
j'ai là la conséquence ultime de la
notification de ce qui se passe de la
non préparation du fait de ne pas
écouter les soignants qui hurlent depuis
des mois on nous écoute pas il n'y a
aucune mesure de prise et puis
aujourd'hui on se dit ah bah mince alors
on objecte à travailler les gens connus
de positif
ah bah oui hein évidemment on n'a pas le
choix toute façon c'est sa confiance
alors quand on sait que le coby bell
dans notre vie pendant plusieurs années
c'est pas forcément très rassurant alors
il faut un choc absolument il faut faire
un reset total il faut tout changer sur
les organisations actuelles qui sont
complètement obsolète c'était fumisterie
quand j'entends le ministre de la santé
dira s'il a prévu quatre mille il ya
quelques jours avec 50 millions d'euros
enfin bon les caps navy sont annoncés
depuis le mois de juillet je suis senior
alors c'est très étonné parce que je
pensais qu'il y aurait tout le monde
qu'ils trouveraient ça choquant et je
vois quand même y en a deux qui ne
trouve pas ça choquant nicolas pourquoi
est ce que ça ne vous choque pas que des
soignants
ils sont testés positifs a eu malgré
tout travailler parce que ce que dit
monsieur est terrible c'est à dire que
on n'a pas le choix et que à un moment
donné c'est pas juste dix ans oui ça va
changer quoi que ce soit c'est qu'on se
retrouve dans une situation grave
aujourd'hui en manque de lits au manque
quand même de soignants ont fait ce que
quand vous dites il ya 106 ans 86 milles
un fermier qui ne veulent pas
aujourd'hui travailler dans les
conditions les cercles effectivement il
faut un plan marshall et pourra dire si
non mais non je veux pas être choqué
parce que si à un moment donné tous les
gens qui ont une colline et on sait pas
jusqu'où ça va aller
comment ça a quitté les hôpitaux un par
un c'est à dire que plus personne ne
soignera demain c'est à dire qu'on
n'aura même pas l'espoir qu'un infirmier
qui a peut-être le commis de me soigne
demain mais en face on n'est ce pas ce
que dit monsieur aussi c'est de dire il
va peut-être vous mettre en danger ou
qui ne l'avait pas qu'est-ce que vous
voulez que je vous dise c'est la période
d'évitement de sept jours c'est pas vous
arrêter pour 2000 magie n'est que tous
les gens qui ont le colibri je sais pas
combien ils sont il faudrait rentrer
dans le temps dans le vif du sujet et
dans l'est
dans le détail aussi des choses mais si
vous avez ne serait-ce que 500
infirmiers aujourd'hui qu'ils sont
porteurs du covin quand vous voyez la
montée en puissance des gens en
réanimation
enfin bordeaux ils vont rester vont
craquer donc ça va être pire que tout
n'est que là on peut aussi supposer que
justement yahia comme le disait monsieur
sept jours à respecter bon il isole sept
joueurs ont bien travaillé
simplement moi ça me fait ça me fait ça
me fait bien rigoler la semaine dernière
il voulait virer un mec qui avait été
testé positif et qui finalement était
lui virer du travail très sages sont les
soignants mais quand bien aimé ce sont
des êtres humains
nick williams ont dénoncé parce qu'une
tuerie de masse qui ai laissé faire
parce que quand vous savez que la
personne que potentiellement contaminés
des personnes saines c'est insupportable
pour moi je veux bien qu emmanuel macron
face des grands coups de com que verront
elles partout à la télé pour dire oui il
faut être solidaire il faut qu'on soit
main dans la main mais merde
est-ce qu'on peut commencer par les
vraies choses au lieu de me faire entrer
chez moi à 21h il ya peut-être d'autres
choses
giteau que des couvre-feux non juste une
question à qui revient la décision de
dire un infirmier au testé positif
tu viens quand même à qui revient cette
décision c'est l'administration
d'administration est clairement ils ont
la main là vous avez un travailleur
indépendant
ceux qui sont vacataires ceux qui sont
contractuels ceux qui sont stagiaires
dans leur force la main ont le temps on
leur tord le bras
vous avez beaucoup de choses à dire sur
ce sujet magali une question monsieur
merci est-ce que vous avez l'obligation
excuse absolue obligation de prévenir
les patients par exemple cet infirmier
là qui est attendu qu'ovide moi
personnellement si je dois me faire
tester je voudrais pas qu'une test c'est
ça mais est ce que cette personne a
l'obligation de me le dire au moins que
je puisse au moins décider de ce qui
peut m'arriver ou pas où ils peuvent
aller sans vous le sachiez vous faire un
test alors qu'ils sont malades dicko
vide ah non non non donc il a veut dire
qu'on peut être effectivement comme le
dit mais très jolie devant ma grille se
faire soigner par un infirmier qui
lui-même et porteurs asymptomatiques et
dont on ne saura rien il peut peut-être
que sept jours ou 14 jours après nous on
va développer la maladie
ce ne sera pas que c'est lui qui la
donne et oui ça c'est grave situation
emilie je vous vois atterré ouais je
suis atterré et surtout je pense à eux
parce qu'en fait cote quand on fait ce
genre de métier on veut donner sa vie
pour sauver celle des autres et je me
dis que les forcer à faire ça pour eux
ça être une angoisse et une culpabilité
de dingue
de se dire chaque personne que je vais
croiser mais déjà psychologiquement ils
viennent de vivre une période qui était
compliqué là c'est un nouveau coup de
massue et je pense que ben on va se
retrouver dans les situations il y en a
certains et j'en ai bien peur qu'ils y
voilà qui au-delà de là ils vont arriver
vouloir se [ __ ] en l'air quoi kevin à
kevin vous êtes vous aussi je suis pas
choqué et dans le sens encore m'en
étonner
aujourd'hui c'est la conséquence de ce
qui se passe depuis des mois on savait
ce qui allait arriver
ça date pas d'aujourd'hui les
manifestations régulières les coups de
gueule réguliers les soignants ce sont
des gens que je défendrai corps et âme
tous les jours ils n'ont pas le choix
aujourd'hui le problème c'est que même
où vous allez peut-être confirmer ce que
je vous dis même du personnel qui en
unité qu vide quand il ya plus de
personnes on va chercher les gens des
autres étages ses autres personnes ne
sont pas forcément tester où on est là
tout de suite maintenant est ce que tu
dis magali a le secret médical vous
n'êtes pas obligé de dire que vous êtes
contaminés ou pas donc là c'est un peu
le serpent qui se mord la queue
c'est facile de dire on est choqués on
est choqué oui mais on est chaud
qu'aujourd'hui mais c'est la conséquence
de tout ce qui se passe aujourd'hui donc
un moment de livrer concrètement
monsieur bart typiquement si tous les
infirmiers exercer une sorte de droit de
retrait en disant écoutez moi je n'ai
pas du tout envie de prendre le risque
de mettre quelqu'un en situation de
tomber malade l'hôpital s'effondre si
les pvd affirmé porter de kobe devienne
pas travailler non non mais par contre
il faut absolument donner les moyens de
pouvoir lutter comprenez bien que la
première vague ce qui a été terrible
c'est que nous avons en france pour 1000
habitants 5,9 me l'allemagne 8 au niveau
des lits de réanimation nous avons que
5000 lits de réanimation l'allemagne 25
mille cinq fois plus et ils ont eu
quatre fois moins de morts pourquoi
parce que lorsqu'on manque de ligne que
vous avez un solide rien
vous avez trois patients eh bien vous
devez faire un choix et en a deux qui
vont mourir en service vous êtes en
train de dire là et on dit ça on l'avait
un peu effleuré on n'osait pas le dire à
voix haute que de toute façon vous allez
être en situation de devoir faire des
choix qui va bien sûr qui ne va pas
vivre mais c'est ce qui s'est passé et
c'est ce qui nous a manqué c'est à dire
ce que pour
les directions pour le gouvernement
c'est des chiffres eux ils sont dans le
souk pertes
trente deux mille morts 67 millions
c'est ridicule pour nous c'est un visage
c'est un nom si on rêve d'une histoire
de vie c'est nous qui accompagnant la
famille c'est nous qui devons expliquer
que non il n'ira pas en réanimation et
et ça ça nous a broyé une nous soignons
il ya 10 % des infirmières qui sont
épuisement professionnel en dépression
certainement stress post traumatique
après ce qui s'est passé c'est donc il
faut bien comprendre qu'il est urgent de
rouvrir des lits de créer des postes
parce qu on on supprime des postes et il
faut redonner envie à tous et soignants
qui peuvent travailler revenir à leur
talent allez on ne veut pas accepter de
travailler dans des conditions
dangereuses pour les patients parce
qu'on a une déontologie
on a des valeurs et on accepte plus
n'importe quoi